if we were to break down the amount of
content you consume okay percentage-wise
in the last 12 months okay
what percentage of your research and
reading is the market like the whole
Market what percentage is purely crypto
what percentage is politics
if you were to break that down if you
know 40 of what I consume is this 20 is
this 10 is this
I would say something like a quarter is
politics and a quarter is macro
economics and uh and a quarter is is the
crypto economy and and uh Bitcoin
related things in the crypto economy and
the last 25 percent is is uh
microstrategy
business activity you know our Capital
operations Capital Market structures and
and and our uh strategic initiatives so
there's nothing that is more than the
other you're you're evenly split amongst
the four very interesting how you do
that I I would say I'm evenly split
amongst the four I I'm quite aware that
that my impact is at the microstrategy
level I get to decide you know whether
we're going to pay off a 205 million
dollar loan or not right I get to decide
whether we're going to issue a billion
dollars of equity or not and I get you
know so I have an impact over what
microstrategy is doing as the chairman
of microstrategy and I have a
responsibility to my employees my
shareholders and the like so a lot of my
work is there and then
I have the ability to have an impact and
a need to to be engaged in the crypto
economy especially so I'm spending a lot
of time on bitcoin Bitcoin education
lightning development of Bitcoin
applications and lightning Network those
sort of things right that's where I
could have an impact and the macro
economy I study it because I want to
know what's going on with China and
Russia and interest rates and
hyperinflation in Argentina but I I
don't you know I I have uh
no belief that I'm going to be able to
control that right like I don't pretend
to be able to direct Argentine
macroeconomic policy and with regard to
politics in general
you got to pay attention to what's going
on with you know the Tucker Carlsons of
the world and you got to pay attention
to the presidential race and and the
politics the Senate and Congress and the
regulatory activities but it's above my
pay grade right I have a there's a
hundred things that are going on the
political sphere and when you say above
my period I don't have control over it
is what you mean I a you know I don't
control over it B my opinion is not
welcomed
right
ability right I'm not going to express
strongly held opinions on medical policy
or interest rate policy or or the like
because it is distracting and so I I
think you have to study it yeah and you
and you know I have to know where the
wind is going for example there are some
countries I would not live in right now
I'm not going to tell you which ones I'm
just not going there are some places I
would not go right so same in countries
that people you would assume are safe to
live in
why wouldn't you traditionally I'm look
there's a war going on in the Ukraine
right so yeah I mean do you pay
attention do you pay attention right
there are places I wouldn't make an
investment sure there are places I would
not go there are places I would not live
right uh but if you look at my Twitter
profile I have laser eyes
and and the significance of laser eyes
is if you want to make progress in this
world you have to focus and Channel all
of the energy you have behind a very
very particular objective and I have one
laser-like Focus right Bitcoin is good
money right Bitcoin is good for the
world Bitcoin is is a is global Freedom
Global property rights interesting right
like
I have a hundred other opinions but if
if I actually filled my feed with here's
what I think about bicycles and here's
what I think about diets and here's what
I think about health and here's what I
think about you know labor policy and
here's what I think about states rights
and here's what I think about this
country at some point uh you just dilute
your focus
and you just you don't have that much
energy in this life so if you like this
clip and you want to watch another one
click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
foreign